hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space - all right we're
going this way but now let's make sure
that I cover all the what what all right
maybe um haha nope ha ha ha depart
you're just yours whoopee is no normal
ones with your other arm there
ha ha got ya business yeah
so I'll takes care of those guys all
right now I'm headed towards I'm
guessing the marker
no aah no hold still damn it
ah what oh you not much but here's an
arm set up an arm and a leg they usually
go down okay one of these guys help Oh
my thanks whoa not today off [ __ ] ah no
not today buddy all right
I really shouldn't be using those set
such close range whoops missed you
because well I mean it's just basically
asking no dammit it's asking for that
nozzle really oh oh you're not
another one only crap this is thousands
of it No
all right Wow
I couldn't have handled that worse I
really I just totally screwed everything
about that up yeah this bodes well if I
ever do a live stream gonna be sad sad
sad I'll be like what I plan to do is
I'm gonna do a live stream of this in
hardcore mode once I beat this game
which might even be tomorrow I don't
know how much game is left but once I do
I'm gonna do once and I'm only gonna
give myself one life if I ever die I
know it's you can get through sales but
if I ever die ever
I will not okay oh I forgot
suck on that no get back
ah god damn it oh I forgot this does
like no damage if it's not armed double
brown there we go yeah
which might mean that it's going to be a
short game but I'm gonna when I do play
it fair I will be picking and choosing
my games better Manama games my weapon
is better I'm not gonna be experimenting
I'm gonna stick with a very basic set of
guns and I got the leg walk over that
what up
oh-ho cut your friend shut up about
nothing
okay
so well that was a mistake I wasted my
stupid launcher Hey
ha ha that did it Oh ah from behind come
on come on over all right
not so bad eh not too shabby once I do a
little plan
and there were a lot of we can still
hear one more anyway no I knew it there
is one more oh not today buddy oh wow
one shot anymore anymore Bueller Bueller
no okay and finally hey that was a lot
in such a confined area had people at
least 20 hours coming out of the walls
that maybe not that many 1600 audio log
system built into the shielding around
the marker test bed should be blocking
the signal entirely by soon I just think
what's still getting through nothing
registered on any sensor outside to seal
all the same security side with the
marker and it goes off the charts so we
either with something entirely uh but
yeah things are going bad man
yeah okay
oh oh it's gone how it drop all right so
I'm making a with Cru not exactly sure
om I'll be very very specific on the
power notes during the hardcore ah
speaking up like only fully upgrading
the weapons that I use and it does mean
it does mean that I will be rocking the
pulse rifle because I got very good with
the balls right I really do think it's
whoa who's that
ah shut up
slow down suck on this and ah ah
suck all back and burn yo that's not my
burner
it's my burn burn [ __ ]
all right all right that does that luck
whoa
ah-ha-ha
so you get away from me nothing escapes
my wrath okay yeah arsenal bobby-boy
actually a probably plasma cutter
pulse rifle and detonator because
detonators excellent in very specific
situations just not all over pass the
eatery definitely the release okay
Rocco okay this way that locked yes long
okay
uh-oh that looks familiar
how did that get in there already oh
it's one of these levels I saw that
there it's cross be are you giving me
the right answer if they know hello
wow I see you peekaboo
come on bit
with that dude I see an empty one over
there oh go over yes okay all right got
a pretty well locked up I don't think
they're gonna be getting through well I
mean they're gonna come at me but
they're not going to me that's really
interesting they like peek their head up
like hello who's there what's going on
whoa one go off no one did not go on
what ela oh [ __ ] ah bring it
nope that's what I thought ah [ __ ] [ __ ]
Sonia okay don't charge yet hang on
there we go
ah stop you [ __ ]
there we go ah where knees up up I do
damn it No Oh Phil no come on
oh come on all right this guy I might
have been no oh hello what are you doing
over there just doing losing a leg
Oh Oh
any of you know what that's from
Oh
it's not from like a Barbara never mind
never mind not even worth going into the
details okay got that ah ah yep can't
get me a chair
thank you picture kind of you know
Bonnie
so I'm smart is that what you're saying
but use me as I drool all over myself
I'd say I'm smart too baby
all right saving here dunk how many
chapters were there in dead space one
only two only twelve right whoa we're
getting close your eyes are the marker
knows you're here does that qualify is
just noise I don't trust you
you're probably gonna make me do
something that
oh that's building
ah baby sure get that baby turn you this
oh hello ah get the barrack okay hi I'm
Tara don't fail me now where'd you go
oh I don't look good oh my god like a
lot of them thanks Isaac I figured that
out actually
whoa not bad
give me the bun goodies ah babies I say
baby ah final shoot it waste ammo that
baby clear okay he said something about
you know I could have triggered a doubt
Wow what does give me that whoa ah no
good that guy's not looking oh my
goodness that my goodies gonna flying
hello
alright I'm just gonna make it through
one more sure no doubt wrong
all those miss Shoop
all right there we go got it another one
pop in here some more babies
oh no more babies Oh
baby another baby why why would I have
to do this why does this make sense to
anybody up yep Ariel alright we so much
fun ah no not like that
ah where'd you come from
receive okay I'm good I'm okay don't
need to scream little bit scary
yeah the plasma cutter is like my
favorite all around 11:00 it's just it's
great oh now I can turn them off of
course
don't know what that dude oh hello oh
grip
telekinesis telecasts Tenex
hello callus step Alex Denis
I don't know stop looking at me like
that I'm not weird
perfectly normal alright that's all the
time I got for this part thank you guys
so much for watching and as always we'll
see you in the next part bye bye okay
bye bye